most celebrities have a talent like
singing dancing acting but I don't
really know what the Kardashians do I
know that people think that the
Kardashians are stupid but I don't know
how anybody with that much money could
be stupid I don't know why they're right
their late father was a lawyer who
represented OJ Simpson okay that's the
mom she's a good-looking lady and the
moms friend went to a party where the
party favors were viagra it's nice to
see older women talking about sex on
television yet this family seems really
really weird I think Scott might be a
psychopath but he seems like the only
one who has any idea what's going on and
honestly the only one that seems at all
normal is Bruce isn't bad if I like
Scott the mob is drugging Bruce Jenner
with Viagra why is Chris forcing Bruce
do something that he clearly doesn't
want to do now she made another drug to
coffee for the husband but but robbed
her son took it did Rob accidentally
take the pill coffee
her son is gonna have like four days of
boners so he got an erection from his
mom which seems very weird this is like
a classic sitcom like all of these plots
were taken from Three's Company this is
just the worst scripted show in the
world this is in reality so from what I
can tell the Kardashians are very
irritating people but also I kind of
can't look away this is good fodder for
our nights when you're just want the TV
on and you don't actually want to pay
attention to what you're watching I know
that that interview that just came out
with Bruce Jenner was incredibly moving
and incredibly brave and then all the
others came out and Chris showed support
and Kim showed support so really it's
just a family show with Viagra
not enough Kim where's Kim what is she
doing
I like house only now that Kris Jenner
is like I think it might be the coffee